Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Congressman Roe Connor, who
represents California's 17th District, located
in the heart of Silicon Valley.
Congressman, always great to speak with you.
Speaker 5: Always a pleasure, David.
Speaker 1: So there's so many things to talk
about.
Let's start with the United States Innovation
and Competition Act of twenty twenty one,
formally known as the Endless Frontier Act.
What what's the goal here?
What would this legislation do?
Speaker 5: First of all, a big dramatic increase
in science and technology funding of the kind
we haven't seen since the Apollo years, we're
at about point seven percent of GDP in science
research.
Comparatively, China is almost double one
point three percent of their GDP.
This would add two hundred and fifty billion,
over 100 hundred billion of that in science
and technology development.
And it would put this across the country.
So focusing on black communities, brown communities,
rural communities, making sure innovation
is accessible to places left behind.
Speaker 1: When we look at something like
that, Bill, and we look at the infrastructure
proposal and we look at all of these different
big pieces of legislation that that could
be tackled and we run into the inevitable
questions about, OK, in the Senate, does it
need 60 votes?
And if not, can it be done with 50?
But if it can be done with the 50, do Democrats
have 50 or do they have forty nine or forty
eight?
Is this just going to be the question around
every piece of legislation for the foreseeable
future?
Speaker 5: It is.
And look, unfortunately, we're living in a
Senate which is 50.
We thought we would do better.
We didn't we need to do build on that majority
and really living in a house that only has
a five vote majority.
So it is the challenge of governing with slim
majorities and it's the challenge of governing
with a dysfunctional Senate which has a filibuster
rule that allows the minority and a legitimizes
obstruction.
Speaker 1: I don't think you and I have talked
about this.
I mean, in terms of the filibuster, there
are some who say just eliminate it, period,
eliminate it altogether, and then those who
say, but that's also a double edged sword.
There's these intermediate ideas of, well,
instead of saying you need you need 60 to
end debate, make it that you need 40 actual
people to continue pushing it forward and
kind of like flip the onus around or require
it to be a talking filibuster.
What's your view about this issue?
Speaker 5: My view is that we just need to
end the filibuster ended altogether and use
over and over again to suppress and obstruct
civil rights legislation, racial equality
legislation.
In fact, that's been its primary use.
And it was an invention of Calhoon and wanted
to give slave states the power to block progressive
legislation.
But I'm for anything that will advance the
ball.
So we're going to say, OK, we want to have
voting rights be an exception to the filibuster.
I'm for that.
If we're going to put the onus on senators
to actually speak and show up and it's going
to make it much harder to filibuster, I'm
for that.
But ultimately, we need to do away with this
is not part of our Constitution.
It's not part of our founders vision.
Speaker 1: Do you worry about the argument
that is it's a double edged sword and it could
really come back and hurt Democrats when the
political circumstances in the division are
just slightly different?
Speaker 5: For two reasons I don't.
First, the Republicans push their agenda through
anyway.
That's how they got the tax cut.
So a lot of the Republican agenda, let's cut
taxes, but slash government isn't subject
to the filibuster.
It's a lot of our policies that are subject
Second, in a country, I think our problem
is that our politics is too slow.
Our change is too hard.
I worry less between a zig zagging from one
place to another than I worry about institutional
roadblocks and gridlock and our inability
to do things.
Speaker 1: When you think about any of the
bills that you're currently supporting and
that includes USACA and all of these other
things that we're talking about, infrastructure,
etc., we had this ProPublica story a couple
of weeks ago where they identified that relative
to the growth of net worth, which, as I've
explained to my audience, that's not how we
tax in the United States.
We tax unrealized gains, but it exposed that
there are if you're making money from assets
rather than labor, you can until you realize
those gains have significant tax free growth
of of one's net worth.
Do you think that in the context of any bill
that's designed to help workers, that we also
need to be revisiting how we tax assets versus
labor?
Speaker 5: Yes, we need a wealth tax in this
country.
I mean, think about this.
In my district has 10 trillion dollars of
market value in the Bay Area companies.
It's grown 35 percent in the Bay Area.
Ten trillion dollars.
We ought to be taxing some of that.
And a lot of those billionaires, frankly,
would pay the tax.
They won't oppose it.
Instead, this bipartisan bill for infrastructure
is going to fund it by raising the gas tax
on to the index of inflation.
So we're going to tax the working class who
basically have to drive 40 minutes because
they can't afford an apartment in San Francisco
or in New York.
So they are commuting as is.
And we're going to put the burden on them
to pay for infrastructure instead of on the
tech billionaires.
And the multibillionaires produced all this
wealth.
It makes no sense.
Speaker 1: So I don't know about you.
I see an actual tax on wealth as so unlikely
to pass in the next four years that I wonder
how much it's even worth talking about it.
But some of the Biden proposals on either
capital gains or, you know, there's other
ideas that maybe are more politically feasible.
How important do you think it is as someone
who's been advocating for the wealth tax and
other things that, quite frankly, I think
are unlikely to pass anytime soon?
How much is the balance in your mind between
trying to get something done that can actually
be done versus talking about what you see
as the gold standard?
Speaker 5: I think we get do both them and
I mean, Tom Suozzi was a moderate on Ways
and Means and Brendan Boyle, I've actually
come out now for a while, tax at one time.
Well, tax, not like more than two percent
every year.
Yeah, that let's call it the Patriot tax with
the pandemic, all this wealth that was generated.
Let's tax at one time.
So that is because of people like you and
Elizabeth Warren and others who have put the
idea into the public discourse.
And what often happens is it takes years and
then finally something happens.
So we need to continue to do that.
But we can't let the perfect be the enemy
of the good.
And if we can get some solid reforms now,
such as a step up in basis means if you buy
a million dollars of Facebook stock, you hold
it till the end of your life.
If you want to have kids and you give it to
your kids, they should have to pay tax on
the capital gains.
Right now, they don't have to literally you
can die with capital gains never having been
taxed and pass it on to your heirs.
Biden closes that gap and it raises billions
of dollars.
We ought to be increasing the tax on corporations,
so let's get those done.
But ultimately, if you really want to fund
things in this country, we need a Wall Street
financial tax.
We need a wealth tax.
And I don't think that will hurt innovation
or economic growth, but it would fund the
basic infrastructure based on the people who
have made fortunes, inconceivable fortunes.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there's some pretty slick
stuff.
And I don't know if by slick I even mean this
sarcastically or not.
I mean, it's interesting to me that this can
be done.
One can even to build on the idea of the stepped
up basis, one can even borrow against their
portfolio and in a sense, de facto realize
the gains, like you can actually get access
to that growth without even having to pay
the capital gains and pass it on tax free.
I mean, that's quite a mechanism that exists
in the United States tax code.
Speaker 5: It is a dividend.
And trust me that it's all being used by these
billionaires or hiring lawyers.
And, you know, in one sense, you can't blame
them.
I mean, you're they're taking advantage of
rules that Congress has written.
So, yeah, it could be more patriotic, perhaps,
to pay tax.
But how many people are going to say, yeah,
I want to pay more tax than I owe?
Right.
So what we really need to do is change the
rules, make sure that these billionaires who
produce all this wealth are being taxed fairly
on it.
And I don't think a billionaire sitting there
is going to think, OK, maybe I shouldn't,
or an aspiring billionaire.
I'm not going to start the next Google because
the government may take two percent of my
net worth.
That's just not how entrepreneurs think.
Speaker 1: How do you see the sort of tiering
of priorities when it comes to the financial
stuff?
And what I mean by that is sometimes I talk
to people who are on the left who I think
feel pressure to say basically once you're
making a couple hundred thousand dollars a
year or even five hundred thousand dollars
a year, that and making 10 million and one
hundred million and a billion, it should really
be seen in the same the same way you're just
making a ton of money.
And when I actually get into it with a lot
of people, we sort of get to realize that,
you know, there's a big difference between
making three hundred and fifty K with a couple
of kids in a big city versus people who are
making five fifty and five hundred million
dollars a year.
How important do you think it is to approach
those groups differently versus just wrap
everybody together
Speaker 5: is very important.
Approach something differently because of
the real taxes have to be on the ultra rich
and the big corporations, and that's where
the real money is.
And, you know, tax the people who are making
billions of dollars, some of it perhaps legitimately
look, they may have come up with a great idea.
They see the digital revolution.
Sure.
You understand it's transforming an industry.
They're at the forefront of leading that great
celebrated.
But then they have to pay a tax so that society
can transition.
But that's where the real taxes don't go after.
The person who's making a few hundred thousand
already has a couple of kids in college in
the suburbs.
I mean, look, make sure it goes up to thirty
nine percent.
But that's not you don't want to stop the
the middle class or even the upper middle
class you want to do is say we've got we're
going to prioritize the working class, we're
going to look out for the middle class and
upper middle class, but we're really going
to get the revenue from the big corporations
and the ultra rich.
Speaker 1: And I think maybe this is something
that the truly ultra rich really benefit from,
which is that when they are sort of wrapped
in together with folks that are wealthy but
less wealthy, they are maybe better able to
take advantage of the tax law and end up paying
as an effective tax rate, even less like the
ultra rich often end up paying slightly less
than the very rich to distinguish between
two very rich groups.
That maybe is something that would deserve
some significant attention.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
I think we have to treat the ultra rich as
a separate class, given the wealth generation
in this country.
And I, I think taxing them more, in my view,
is in their interests.
And this is why there's so many billionaires,
by the way, in my district who are fine with
the wealth tax.
Yep.
And.
The reason it's in their interest is because
if you want to prevent a resentment and hostility
to wealth generation and a lot of their wealth
generation, in my view, has come through honest,
hard work, creativity and ingenuity.
It's not that they deserve all of the billions.
There are lots of people that went into it.
But it's not that they were just lucky they
didn't work hard.
And but if you want people to celebrate that,
then pay the tax and show that you're generating
that wealth is helping society.
When you don't pay that tax, that's where
you have the resentment.
Speaker 1: Last thing I wanted to ask you
about in terms of budget reconciliation, where
would you like to see it used in order to
get one more big accomplishment in twenty
twenty one?
Speaker 5: Climate, clearly, it has to have
climate in it.
I mean, the infrastructure plan that currently
is on the table is basically a version of
what Trump said.
It has none of the climate goals.
So we need the climate goals in there.
We need a broader vision on tax policy so
that you don't have the working class with
the tax policy.
That would be my my essential part.
I mean, obviously, I want to expand Medicare.
I want prescription drugs out of a hole, a
child care, a whole vision.
But if it's the White House were to call me
and said, what are the must haves, I take
good tax policy and climate.
Speaker 1: Do you agree that for Democrats
to make a solid case for 20, 22, which really
is going to kick off I mean, it might be January,
it really might even be November, December.
Some consultants are saying.
Do you think that Joe Biden needs one more
major accomplishment in addition to vaccine
rollout and covid stimulus this calendar year?
Speaker 5: I do, and I think he'll get one.
But the question is, what kind will it be
if it is just a bipartisan infrastructure
bill that may help and it may help a moderate
swing districts.
But I don't think it's going to mobilize their
base that we need both.e need something to
the independents, swing voters, but we also
need to show our base that we really delivered
on progressive change.
So I would say he needs one big thing that
appeals to the base as well.
Speaker 1: Yeah, a relatively small infrastructure
bill that Mitt Romney loves.
I don't know if that's necessarily going to
count as the progressive change people are
people are waiting for.
Completely agree with you.
We've been speaking with Congressman Rokan,
representing California's 17th District.
Always great having you on, David.
Speaker 5: Always enjoy it.
Thank you.